Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir stehen vor dem Salon. Nein, wir sitzen schon quasi, aber wir sind symbolisch. Heute muss man sehr scharf unterscheiden, was ist symbolisch und was ist echt. Also wir stehen vor dem Salon symbolisch, sitzen aber hier am Tisch.
Und wir treffen uns wirklich hier. Das machen wir nicht immer oder haben das früher nicht immer gemacht. Wir haben immer gesagt im Salon, das können wir sehr gut über den digitalen Weg machen. Aber uns ist dann doch aufgefallen, dass es nochmal ein bisschen dynamischer ist, wenn wir miteinander über die Texte Fass a Fass diskutieren.
Und heute haben wir ja viele, die wir zusammen lesen.
Genau und wir wollen das vielleicht ein bisschen beibehalten, dass wir versuchen, den Salon auch immer gemeinsam hier in Frankfurt aufzunehmen.
Sehr gut. Mir ist es ja, also du erbringst die Fahrtleistung, so will ich sagen. Mir ist es natürlich nicht einerlei. Ich finde es gut, wenn ich hier nicht alleine sitze an meinem technischen Gerät. Denn, Verweis auf Dirk Becker, kommuniziert man dann eigentlich mehr mit dem technischen Gerät oder mit der Person dahinter und das ist dann immer so ein bisschen unklar. Gut, also kleiner Joke zum Thema, was ist symbolisch gemeint und was ist wirklich echt und sind Symbole nicht auch echt. Alle haben sich schon darüber aufgeregt. Ich will es auch nochmal tun. Es gab einen Anschlag in Berlin.
Schlimm, ja.
Was gehört? Es wurde geschenkt und zerstört und zwar nicht irgendwas, sondern das Grundgesetz, von dem ich gar nicht wusste, dass es da steht. Niemand wusste es. Niemand kennt den Künstler. Denn es ist nicht einfach nur das Grundgesetz, sondern es ist ein Kunstwerk. Das allerdings zugestanden. Es ist wirklich sehr hübsch, finde ich. Ich habe es noch auf Bildern gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo es da steht. Ich habe es auch noch nie gesehen. Und dank Ulf Poschat weiß ich auch, es ist übrigens ein israelischer Künstler, dessen Werk dort geschenkt wurde.
Womit Poschat uns nahelegen wollte, jetzt kämpfen die Deutschen schon wieder gegen die Juden.
Woraufhin Stefan Ampermann ja dann auf Twitter noch mal darauf hin, wie es stimmt. Es ist in der Tat ein israelischer Künstler. Und in der Welt war auch schon vor sieben Jahren nachzulesen, dass er ein ganz schlimmer Typ ist, weil er nämlich der israelischen Regierung damals schon rassistische Züge unterstellte.
Ah ja, das wird dann Ulf Poschat wiederum nicht so recht sein.
Es ließ sich aber ausgerechnet in der Welt nachlesen vor sieben Jahren. Also es geht drunter und drüber. Jedenfalls, ich glaube, man kann noch mal so eine kleine, kommentierige Geschichte machen, die ungefähr so abgeht. Du hast bestimmt auch Nachrichten die letzten Tage gehört. Große Aufregung, Tränen überströmte Minister, weltweite Aufruhr. Man hat endlich die Meere gerettet. 30% oder 60% der Meere stehen jetzt unter besonderem Schutz. Es ist der Teil, den man sowieso nicht sieht, nämlich abseits der Küsten, gemeinnah als internationale Gewässer und so, gelabelt, wo bisher gar keine Regeln galten. Es war wie im Weltraum. Man schießt etwas hoch und dann kann man dabei alles machen. Was bedeutet, 500 Tonnen Öl pro Jahr fließen da schon mal rein, weil irgendwelche Schiffe sagen, ich brauche das am Hafen.
Im Weltraum gibt es eigentlich Regeln.
Die wurden aber nicht ratifiziert. Wir haben es gelesen, aber es sind sozusagen Vorschläge. So wie auch für die Meere.
Weil das nicht alles ratifiziert, wird der Weltraum ja auch so verdreckt.
Für die Meere ist auch noch nichts ratifiziert. Die Länder müssen jetzt erst noch. Man ist aber zuversichtlich, dass es geschieht. Jedenfalls gibt es diese großen Gesetzgebungen. Dieses Abkommen für die Meere wird genauso völkerrechtlich bindend sein. Deswegen auch diese Ratifizierungsprozess wie Paris. Und selbst wenn das dann irgendwann mal ratifiziert ist, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass sich jetzt alle dran halten. Siehe Paris. Irgendwann kommt dann also ein Bundesverfassungsgericht und sagt, naja, ihr könnt das jetzt nicht alles so ewig aufschieben. Ihr müsst dann die völkerrechtlichen Verträge, die eingegangen sind, auch mal einhalten. Dann gesteht man den Jungen, damit das auch einen kleinen Happening-Charakter hat, noch so ein neues Grundrecht zu, nämlich auf Zukunft und Freiheit und sowas. Und das wird dann immer fleißig kommentiert. Und irgendwie fragt man sich aber doch, naja, aber wenn wir jetzt die Meere schützen, wenn wir Paris haben, in irgendeinem konkreten Gesetz, das auch irgendwas mal tatsächlich anders regelt, muss das ja münden. Sonst wären das ja alles nur Lippenbekenntnisse. Also es ist ja die EU-Kommission dahinter, genau solche Gesetze zu schreiben. Wir haben ja im Januar 2020 schon erstaunt festgestellt, also Ursula von der Leyen kann gar nicht nur das Geld an Berater rausschmeißen im deutschen Ministerium, sondern die kann ja auch als EU-Kommissarin einfach mal einen richtig großen Aufschlag machen und sagen, wir machen jetzt die neue Wachstumsstrategie und das übrigens Klima. Naja, man hat also so eine sehr viele Jahrzehnte überdauernde Geschichte von großen UN-Klimagipfel, Umweltgipfel, was auch immer, jetzt der Meeresgipfel, das wird dort verabschiedet. Es gibt große Medienanstürme, Interviews, alle sagen, das ist ganz toll. Dann dauert es ein Jahr lang, bis das alles ratifiziert ist, dann interessiert es schon keinen mehr. Und dann werden in den nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahren so Gesetze geschrieben, die dann irgendwie so irgendwo münden. Keiner weiß mehr, ach so, und damit hatte das eigentlich zu tun. Und dann, na gut, hat man halt so kleine Regelungen. Und dann kommt ein Bundesverkehrsminister aus Deutschland und sagt, ich taube dir das jetzt mal, dass es da riesige Abkommen auf UN-Gesetzgebnissen gibt. Das einzige, wie wir nachher bei Heusgens lesen werden, global agierende politische Institutionen überhaupt. Dass das dann in nationale oder auch, das ist ja bei der EU dann auch so supranationale Gesetzgebung mündet, dass das irgendwo tatsächlich mal Folgen hat, wird dann einfach in so einem Handstreich weggewischt. Da heißt es dann einfach, ach so, dieses riesige Abkommen damals, was wir gemacht haben. Und ich bleibe jetzt, weil kein interessiert jetzt, welches Abkommen mündet oder führte dazu, dass es jetzt zu so einem Verbrenner aus für 2035 kam. Man kann ja schon die Parallelgeschichte machen. Ja gut, man hat das Abkommen, aber eigentlich sagen ja auch die ganzen Autohersteller, ja, Audi steigt schon 2033 aus und alle anderen auch. Also die wollen gar keinen Verbrenner mehr nach 35 auf den Markt bringen, weil sie ja genau wissen, wie sich der Zeitenwind gerade dreht. Und die lesen ja auch die Briefe von Larry Fink und so weiter. Klar, da kommt mal eine Pandemie dazwischen, aber trotzdem sind ja die großen Pflöcke da eingeschlagen. Und in dieser Zeit, in der Volker Wissing nochmal sagt, nee, ich ignoriere jetzt die ganze große globale UN-Wir retten das Welt-Geschichte und ich ignoriere auch, wie die EU funktioniert, nämlich, dass da eigentlich schon alles verhandelt ist, sondern nur noch formal der Ministerrat einfach sagt, okay, ist jetzt fertig verhandelt, beschließen wir jetzt, was übrigens dazu führt, das ist ja auch so eine illustre Seitennote, dass am Ende die Landwirtschaftsminister, weil die eben den nächsten Termin in Brüssel haben, einfach das mit auf die Tagesordnungsnähe, dass es ja auch noch zum Verbrenner eine Entscheidung formal abzusegnen gibt, das wird alles ignoriert und Peter Kaperne kann man im Deutschlandfunk zuhören, wie er sich wirklich lustig darüber macht, dass die Deutschen jetzt, naja, wie so eine Horde chinesischer Diplomaten, die man im Grunde einfach nur das Gesicht retten muss die ganze Zeit. Es wird ja nie was konkret gemacht, sondern man ist immer nur bemüht, irgendwie das Gesicht zu retten. Und dann beschreibt er so im Radio, wie, naja, die Drähte heiß klühen zwischen dem Bundesverkehrsministerium und der EU-Kommission, weil man jetzt dadurch, dass er so einen großen medialen Aufschlag gemacht hat, ihm irgendwie das Gesicht retten muss, obwohl alle nur noch schenkelklopfend in der in Brüssel da sitzen und sich darüber lustig machen. Und in dieser Zeit, wo also der Bundesverkehrsminister sagt, nee, wir wollen gar nicht aussteigen, aussteigen, wir wollen weiter Sachen verbrennen, egal woher. Und sei es mit einem extrem niedrigen Wirkungsgrad, dass wir nochmal, eigentlich wollen wir ja Afrika ernähren und so weiter, aber nee, wir müssen das jetzt nochmal in den Tank, das muss verfeuert werden. In dieser Zeit, zeitgleich eigentlich, gibt es in Berlin einen sogenannten Anschlag, in dem symbolisch, und ich meine, selbst wenn es Öl gewesen wäre, wäre es nur symbolisch, aber man hat ja selbst das Öl nochmal ausgetauscht gegen Farbe im Wasser, damit es leicht wegmachen. Also man hat sozusagen symbolisch ein Symbol symbolisiert. Also mehr symbolisch geht eigentlich gar nicht. Und dieser Mediensturm, der dazu stattfand, also während wir eigentlich ein Gesetzeswerk, ein Grundrecht, eine UN-Karte, alles Mögliche haben und die FDP, der einfach so eine Kanne Verbrenner, irgendwas Öl draufgießt, und alles so, ja gut, okay, den müssen wir jetzt mal sein Gesicht retten. Und die Reaktion auf, wir begießen mal kurz eine Glasscheibe mit Gravur, mit Farbe, ist dann irgendwie, dass Michael Roth irgendwie anfängt, einen Twitter-Sturm mit Taliban. Und plötzlich steigen alle darauf ein, dass die letzte Generation sich jetzt ja wie die Taliban verhält.
Genau, und dann ruprecht Polens das noch verteidigt und sagt, na Taliban, das ist halt so eine Metapher. Dann muss man sagen, nee, das ist nicht so eine Metapher, sondern es ist ein direkter Vergleich. Und diesen Vergleich haben ja dann sehr viele gemacht. Und wir haben es ja da mit Rot mit einer Person zu tun, die eigentlich vorgibt, sich außenpolitisch bestens auszukennen und deshalb ja auch besonders schnell für schwere Waffenlieferungen und alles Mögliche ist.
Also Michael Rot ist ja nicht einfach nur irgendein Politiker, sondern der ist ja in der Rolle Staatssekretär im Auswärtigen Amt, dass er als Europaminister gilt. Er ist zuständig für die Europasachen. Er ist also eigentlich ein echter Bindestrich Außenminister, ein richtiger Fachaußenminister. Und als Außenminister kann man gar nicht die Taliban nur symbolisch meinen, denn das fällt in den eigenen Zuständigkeitsbereich. Also wenn man da Taliban schreibt, muss man auch Taliban meinen. Da kann man nicht plötzlich anfangen, irgendwie so eine Privatmeinung, die nochmal erklärt, dass das illustrer gemeint ist. Das ist so daneben. Das ist so crazy. Das ist so grotesk, dass einem wirklich die Worte fehlen bei dem, was man da gerade beobachtet.
Besonders albern finde ich ja bei der Angelegenheit, dass es diese Diskussion gibt, diese Klimaaktivisten verachten das Grundgesetz. Dem ist ja gar nichts. Sondern sie beziehen sich mit dieser Aktion auf das Grundgesetz. Wenn man das Grundgesetz verachten würde, würde man sich ja gar nicht mehr auf das Grundgesetz beziehen. Dann würde man sagen, was schert mich das Gesetz? Ich mache hier mein eigenes. Aber indem man symbolisch diese Aktion durchführt, bezieht man sich auf das Grundgesetz, um damit zu verdeutlichen, man hält sich gerade von Seiten der Politik nicht an das, was eigentlich im Grundgesetz steht. Und dass man aber glaubt, dass eine Schändung, wenngleich man ja auch schon einhaken müsste, was soll geschändet werden? Das Grundgesetz ist ja erst mal ein Gesetz. Das ist ja nicht tatsächlich die Tafel.
Man kann ein Gesetz nicht schänden. Das muss man echt mal...
Das ist unsinnig. Aber auch darüber hinaus ist es absoluter Unsinn. Und ebenso blöde, finde ich, dann die ganzen Twitter-Clowns, linksliberal, neoliberal, die die ganze Zeit jetzt sagen, naja, aber die erweisen der Sache keinen guten Dienst, diese Aktivisten. Denn jetzt wird ja gerade wieder über etwas anderes geredet. Ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass in den Sendungen von Anne Will, Micky Beisen, zum wie sie alle heißen, das Klimathema sonst immer großgemacht wird. Und jetzt müssen wir leider über die Aktivisten reden. Nein, entweder reden die über Corona und Waffen oder die reden jetzt dann vielleicht über die schlimmen Klimaaktivisten. Aber über das Klima wird sowieso nicht geredet, wie auch über Mieten nicht geredet.
Genau, das, was du jetzt ansprichst, war ja der Tenor des Bundesinnen-Mysteriums. Wir reden ja nicht über irgendwelche Leute, die ja einfach twittern, sondern es war ja Nancy Faeser, die sich direkt zitieren ließ. Also diese Tweets sind ein Anführungszeichen mit dem Verweis auf, das sind die Worte der Ministerin. Und sie schrieb dann in ihrem dritten Tweet, weil es reicht ja nicht einer, man muss ja ein ganzes Thread schreiben, diese völlig unwürdige Aktion muss nun konsequent strafrechtlich verfolgt werden. Die Klimakrise können wir nur demokratisch bekämpfen. Dafür braucht es Rückhalt in unserer Gesellschaft. So ein Unsinn schadet deshalb dem Klimaschutz gewaltig. Das zeigt ja, wir sind hier, sagt auch Nancy Faeser, nur auf der Medienbühne. Wir müssen ja, also Rückhalt heißt ja, wir kriegen es nur zusammen mit Opa Enno hin. Jetzt ist aber die Erfahrung der jungen Leute, Opa Enno will das gar nicht. Wir sagen, wir müssen es gegen Opa Enno erkämpfen. Wir haben versucht, ihn auf unsere Seite zu ziehen, es hat nicht funktioniert. So, außer dass es halt Bundesverfassungsgerichtssprüche oder so gibt, passiert da nicht viel.
Selbst wenn Opa Enno das will, wen hätte er denn wählen müssen, damit es umgesetzt wird? Also wir haben ja tatsächlich auch eine Koalition, in der die Grünen keine ganz schwache Partei sind. Und da ist die Enttäuschung entsprechend groß. Also es ist ja auch keineswegs so, dass wenn der Wählerwille mal da ist, der umgesetzt wird. Die meisten Menschen in Berlin hätten gerne andere Wohnverhältnisse, bessere. Trotzdem wird das natürlich nicht umgesetzt.
Und sie machen einen Vollentscheid, der eigentlich in ein Gesetz münden muss, dass man einfach da aufgehalten wird. Also diese Aktionen, ich habe sie so gesehen, habe dann gedacht, okay, wie finde ich das? Keine Ahnung. Dann habe ich gesehen, was für ein Sturm losging und habe mir noch mal Gedanken gemacht. Und ich finde sie eigentlich ähnlich raffiniert, wie diese Tomatensuppe in London, über die wir ja einzeln gesprochen hatten, wir haben ja nur über die Tomatensuppe in London gesprochen, als primäre Pionieraktion vor dem Kartoffelbrei und so weiter. Und diesmal würde ich sagen, es ist nicht so wahnsinnig raffiniert. Man kann nicht so eine Van Gogh-Geschichte noch mit reinbauen und das Bild selbst, sondern okay, es ist als Grundgesetz und es steht auf einem öffentlichen Raum. Muss man auch noch mal dazu sagen, dieses Ding steht auf der Straße. Die Straße ist ein wahnsinnig öffentlicher Raum, der öffentlichste Raum, den wir haben. Jeder darf da einfach hingehen. Und Sachen, die reversibel sind, gehen sowieso nicht. Wie kann das eine Schändung sein, wenn man es einfach abwischen kann? Nicht mal so ganz plump fragen. Ich finde es eigentlich raffiniert, wie plump die Aktion ist. Man guckt sich die deutsche Geschichte an und stellt sich fest, wir sind wahnsinnig stolz auf Grundgesetz. Klar, Artikel 1 kennen wir alle, Artikel 2, da wird es schon schief. Die anderen Artikel kennen wir nicht so genau. Aber das Grundgesetz, ganz schön bedeutend. Dann könnte man aber als junger Mensch daneben stehen und sagen, hier fehlt doch noch irgendwas. Hier fehlt doch so eine Art Zuckerguss. Oder vielleicht sogar ein Fundament, auf dem das alles steht. Das ist eine riesige Kanne Öl, die einfach in die Umwelt geworfen wird. Das haben sie halt dann einfach ergänzt. Da fehlt da halt einfach was, wenn man sich die Zeit der Entwicklung anschaut und sagt, eigentlich fehlt hier noch mal so eine Kanne Öl, die man einfach drauf schmeißt. Wir lesen heute einen Text von Marcel Fratscher, der auch noch mal augenöffnend ist. Er hat dann im Spiegel in seiner Kolumne geschrieben, alle Welt, und zwar die europäische und uns, vor der er dann vorgemacht ist, ist alle Welt, regt sich darüber auf, dass in Amerika jetzt Staatsgeld verwendet wird, um den Klimaschutz zu forcieren. Weil das sind ja Subventionen und wir mögen ja keine Subvention. Und dann stellt er einfach mal gegenüber, ja in dem Maße, wie die Amerikaner jetzt 370 Milliarden Dollar zur Verfügung stellen, um dort grüne Technologie protektionistisch zu fördern, in dem Maße gewichtet, um die Bevölkerungsgröße, subventionieren wir jedes Jahr die fossile Industrie. Und das ist genau diese Kanne Öl, die in Berlin da jetzt einfach mal ausgegossen wurde, symbolisch auf dem Grundgesetz, weil sie da fehlte. Und weil man mal darauf hinweisen musste, dass da noch ein kleiner Zuckerguss fehlt, in der Gesamtbetrachtung dieses Grundgesetzes, auf das wir so stolz sind, da einfach rosinenpickerisch rangehen und sagen, das Grundgesetz finden wir ziemlich gut. Naja, die Geschichte drum herum hat halt noch so ein paar Ausläuferfassetten und Exkursen, die auch noch wichtig sind, aber das ignorieren wir mal. Wir feiern nur das Grundgesetz. Ne, das Grundgesetz lebt, es wird angewendet und so weiter. Und da steckt eben einiges drin, das dazu führt, dass wir es in Deutschland, also insbesondere in Deutschland, mit einem Primat der Wirtschaft zu tun haben, den wir so als Selbstverständliche nehmen, dass wir es gar nicht, also alles, was so orto-liberal oder die angebotsorientierte Wirtschaftspolitik und so weiter, da geht Staat und Politik so in Hand in Hand, Staat und Wirtschaft, dass man gar nicht gemerkt hat, dass eigentlich die Wirtschaft alles steuert, dass Marcel Fratzscher es auch mal aufgerufen hat, wir lesen dann im Salon im Detail zu sagen, ne, wir brauchen jetzt eigentlich mal eine etwas agilere Funktionsweise, in der sich die Wirtschaft auch mal durch das ein und rande Nadel durchzwängen muss und nicht einfach nur sagen kann, Hilfe, Hilfe, Staat, wir brauchen hier Hilfe. Und da will ich einen Clip spielen. Wir haben alle gehört, dass oder wir haben zwei Sachen gehört. Mercedes-Benz hat einen Rekordgewinn. 20 Milliarden Euro im Jahr. 2022, eigentlich ein Krisenjahr und so, aber nicht für die deutschen Autohersteller. Man hat den Gewinn um 28 Prozent gesteigert auf 20, 5 Milliarden Euro. Man verdient also jeden Monat mehr als eine Milliarde Euro. Und gleichzeitig beantragt man kurz bei der Geld. Man geht also zum Staat und sagt, könnt ihr mal bitte das Gehalt für unsere Mitarbeiter zahlen? Und der Staat so, Mist, wir haben ja ein Gesetz, in dem das drin steht, dass das geht. Und jetzt haben sie es angemeldet, das muss noch nicht begründet werden. Das muss noch angemeldet werden. Ja, dann bezahlen wir jetzt aus Steuergeld mal die Gehälter für Mercedes-Benz-Angestellte, während das Unternehmen selbst 20 Milliarden Gewinn macht im Jahr. Und dann hören wir Michael Hüther und Bert Rürup, also der eine Chefvolkswirt, der Chefökonom des Handelsblatt. Also so eine schöne ausgedachte, was können wir dem Opa noch für einen Erntitel geben?
Nadenposten, ja.
Chefökonom des Handelsblatt, oh Gott, oh Gott. Und Michael Hüther, Institutschef Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft. Der Name sagt ja alles. Und wir hören uns mal diese 35 Sekunden an. Die reden darüber, dass ja Mercedes jetzt Kortzarbeiter, also Staatsgeld beantragt, um Gehälter zu bezahlen, wer tatsächlich Rekordgewinne macht. Und besonders gut finde ich diesen allerletzten Michael Hüther will eigentlich noch mal so einen saloppensatz sagen und dann fällt ihm auf, ne, wenn ich den jetzt sage, wäre das total doof, dann versucht er noch mal hinzubiegen.
Finde ich auch nicht gerade ein gutes Bild, was die Unternehmen abgeben, als wenn eine langfristige Umbau, eine Volkswirtschaft sich letztlich an Subventionen entscheidet.
Ja, ist auch.
Die immer nur kurzfristig sind.
Es ist zwar rechtlich zulässig, aber noch ein bisschen da, sagen wir mal, degutant, dass Mercedes auf der einen Seite absolute Rekordgewinne ausweist, aber dann noch Kurzarbeitsgeld haben möchte. Das ist sehr, es ist legal, aber ja, es hat ein Geschmäckle meines Erachtens.
Ja, ob es eine Legitimität in sich trägt, das ist dann noch eine andere Frage, das muss jeder wissen.
Er wollte ja eigentlich am Ende sagen, ganz vorsichtig sein. Er wollte eigentlich am Ende sagen, ob das dann noch eine Legalität in sich trägt, muss halt jeder selber wissen. Und dann fiel ihm auf, wenn ich das jetzt sage, das muss einfach jeder selber wissen, so ist es halt. Nehmt es mal hin, das geht nicht. Lass ich das eine Wort weg, das muss jeder wissen. Das sollte mal jeder wissen, wie das so in Deutschland abläuft. Bitte informiert euch. Also das ist so Banane.
Aber man könnte sich gut vorstellen, wenn es um irgendwas ging, dass ein Hartz-V-Empfänger sich nochmal 50 Euro irgendwo hergeholt hat, dann würde man nochmal richtig in die Vollen gehen und sagen, um Gottes Willen, hier wird wieder schmarotzt ohne Ende. Und so muss man es, glaube ich, einfach frameen. Das ist Schmarotztum, was da stattfindet. Und das haben wir damals schon bei Kellenius gehört, bei dieser Hauptversammlung, bei der Daimler Hauptversammlung, als er sagte, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob wir im nächsten Jahr wieder so einen hohen Gewinn machen können, denn das Kurzarbeitergeld läuft ja dann aus.
Ja, genau. Also damit werden direkt Gewinne von Unternehmen finanziert. Das ist so grotesk, dass man einfach sagen muss, ja, über sehr Platter muss Geld abgeworfen werden, Medien wirksam. Und ja, auf das deutsche Grundgesetz muss Öl geworfen werden, damit das einfach vollständig ist. Das Bild ist sonst nicht vollständig. Also wir kommen auf Radscha nachher zurück im Salon. Es ist grotesk und was unsere Politiker auf Twitter abgezogen haben, ist so unwürdig. Also man muss eigentlich alle Kritik, die sie gegenüber der Aktion von letzter Generation ihnen gegenüber nochmal machen. Und das ist ja ein Phänomen, das fällt einem immer wieder auf. Friedrich Merz sitzt ja nicht einfach im Bundestag und sagt, wir haben ja ein Problem mit aufmerkenden Jugendlichen, mit Migrationshintergrund und so weiter. Sondern er übernimmt die Pascha-Pose, um ihnen Paschartum vorzuwerfen. Er sitzt bei Markus Lanz und sagt, er hat den Satz eigentlich schon fertig, die Jungs sind da sehr die kleinen Paschas. Und wie so ein Pascher macht er diesen Spruch. Und das sehen wir gerade immer wieder. Also es gibt in den Niederlanden so einen witzigen Spruch. Ich kann kein Niederländisch leider, deswegen würde ich ihn gerne sagen. Aber vielleicht kann uns das mal jemand, der das kennt, als Autokommentar aufsprechen. Was du anderen unterstellst, bist du ja selber. Du schaust immer in einen Spiegel. Und das haben wir gerade bei den Politikern und nicht nur bei denen, auch bei den Publizisten, Bernd Ulrich und so weiter. Überall gesehen flächendeckend dieses Phänomen, dass man eigentlich daneben steht und sagt, ja die haben echt so einen Punkt, so einen Nerv getroffen. Das schlechte Gewissen tritt jetzt echt zutage. Man versucht es nochmal mit so einem Überaktionismus zu überspielen, dass man eigentlich im Kern ganz schön getroffen wurde. In deren Sicht Michael Roth und so. Ja, du hast jetzt öffentlich kommuniziert, aber du gehst ja auch abends nach Hause, hast Feierabend, verbringst ein bisschen Zeit mit deinen eigenen Gedanken und kommst vielleicht zu anderen Schlüssen. Aber man wünscht es sich.
Bleiben wir doch bei dieser Überreaktion. Denn es ist doch ganz erstaunlich zu sehen, wie die Leute, die für Verhandlungen eintreten oder die sogar das Wagenknecht-Manifest unterschrieben haben, öffentlich angegangen werden und was da für ein empörter Ton zu vernehmen ist. Und dann auch über jede Geschmacksgrenze hinaus. Ich will das nicht nochmal alles zitieren, wenn dann Leute aus der Friedensbewegung als Zellhaufen betitelt werden und so weiter. Das wollen wir jetzt gar nicht hier groß kommentieren. Wir wollen auch nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir ja keineswegs Leute sind, die Wagenknecht feiern, sondern wir haben in einem früheren Salon über das Wagenknecht Buch ja auch mal gesprochen. Beziehungsweise du hast darüber ausführlich gesprochen. Du hattest jetzt nämlich gelesen, die Selbstgerechten. Aber das soll jetzt mal keine Rolle spielen, sondern ich habe mich natürlich auch hier gefragt, welcher psychologische Effekt ist das eigentlich, dass Leute derart ausrasten, wenn sie auch nur Verhandlungen Frieden hören, wenn sie auch so sehr sich einzelnen distanzieren, immer nur sehen wollen, das sind Russlands Trolle, das sind Putins Leute, was ja wohl auf die allerallermeisten überhaupt nicht zutrifft. Aber das ist dann so ein ganz dummes Erklärungsmuster, dass man sich zurechtgelegt hat und dann kann man entsprechend eskalieren, weil Putin böse ist, sind all seine Unterstützer, ist auch und dann ist jedes Mittel recht. Und du hast jetzt gerade eben angedeutet, ja, das sind jetzt auch so diese aufgeschreckten, die Boomer, die jetzt nochmal so richtig vorgeführt bekommen. So geht es nicht weiter. Und ich habe mich gefragt, ob nicht diese Texte, die wir heute auch verhandeln von Habermas und Kluge und ob nicht auch gewisse Stimmen, die für Verhandlungen sind, die Frieden wollen, ob die nicht gerade deshalb so viel gegen Wehr erfahren, weil sich schon die Diskussion um den Krieg gerade sehr verschiebt. Wir hören selbst von Paul Ronzheimer. Es sieht da zum Teil richtig grauslich aus. Und es geht da auch nicht wirklich voran. Wir haben immer noch einen anderen Ton. Ich spiele ihn jetzt nur mal gerade vor, weil ich ihn so besonders furchtbar fand. Es gab eine Friedensdemo Solidarität mit der Ukraine. Ein Jahr Krieg und da war Luisa Neubauer zu Gast. Und spricht dann dort. Und das hören wir uns mal gerade an, was sie da sagte.
Heute entscheiden wir uns für offene Arme und offene Herzen und echtes Ja, ein echtes Ja zu Ukraine und zu allen Menschen, die dort hier und überall unter Putin leiden müssen. Wir entscheiden uns heute hier für einen Frieden, der was meint, der was wert ist und von dem wir wissen, dass er einen Preis hat. Und wir sind auch hier, weil wir wissen, dass wir bereit sind, ihn zu zahlen.
Ja, den Preis zahlen aber nicht Luisa Neubauer und die Jiren, sondern den Preis zahlen die Menschen in der Ukraine. Deswegen ist das, um es ganz klar zu sagen, reines Maulheldentum, wenn man in Berlin steht und von einem Preis spricht, dem man bereit ist zu zahlen. Und selbst wenn man es auf das, was Deutschland bereit ist zu zahlen, höhere Energiekosten oder so anwendet, dann muss man auch sagen, da wird Luisa Neubauer mit ihren Vermögensverhältnissen auch nicht von groß betroffen sein. Also was hier als große Aufopferung beschrieben wird, meint nur die anderen. Das heißt, das ist eine Rede, die sich eigentlich verbietet. Aber wir kommen jetzt mal zu Stimmen, die wir gehört haben und die sehr für schwere Waffenlieferungen alles sind, die immer gesagt haben, ja, Scholz, Zaudat und all das. Und dann hört man aber plötzlich auch ganz andere Töne jetzt und das zeigt, wie verfahren die Lage ist des Krieges. Und vielleicht ist diese, das wäre jetzt meine Arbeitsthese, vielleicht ist die Aggression gegen die, die für Handlung wollen und dergleichen deshalb so groß, weil jetzt gerade diejenigen, die die ganze Zeit gesagt haben, die Ukraine muss gewinnen oder Putin muss gestürzt werden und all das, plötzlich sehen, wahrscheinlich wird es auf irgendetwas rauslaufen, das nicht dieser Maximalforderung entspricht. Und dann ist Katrin Eigendorf ZDF-Korrespondentin in der Ukraine, ist zu Gast bei einem MDR-Talk und wird da gefragt vom Moderator, wie es denn momentan aussieht und das sind dann die Töne, die wir davon nehmen.
Du kommst aus Kiew, du kommst von der Front, wie ist die Stimmung dort, was würdest du beschreiben, was ist im Moment dort das, was die Leute bedenken, was sie ängstigen, was sie hoffen?
Ich pausiere mal kurz. Diese Frage kann man natürlich so nicht stellen. Das ist ja unglaublich. Du kommst aus der Ukraine, wie ist die Stimmung dort, dann fällt ihm auf, es geht ja gar nicht um Fußballspiel. Also fügt er nochmal an. Hier kann man wirklich so eine Art Verlegenheit von jemanden hören, wir hören uns das nochmal an, der so mittendrin feststellt, ich frage hier im falschen Modus, ich frage nach der Stimmung. Also muss ich da nochmal drei, vier ganz düstere Worte, die man in dem Moment erst einfallen, einfach hinterher machen, um sozusagen wieder zu verdecken, dass ich eigentlich gerade im, ach so, ja, ich bin im Studio und es leuchtet und das Happening muss abgefeiert werden. Welches ist denn? Ach so, es ist gar nicht Fußball.
Jürgen, du kommst von der Front. Wie ist die Stimmung dort? Was würdest du beschreiben? Was ist im Moment dort das, was die Leute bedenken, was sie ängstigen, was sie hoffen?
Also ich würde sagen, in der ganzen Zeit, und ich habe diesen Krieg ja von Anfang an begleitet, haben die Menschen dort verschiedene Etappen durchgemacht. Und die Etappe, in der wir uns jetzt befinden, ist ein Land am Tiefpunkt. Weil die Ukrainer haben natürlich jetzt verstanden, dass die Schrecken dieses Krieges nicht zu Ende sind, sondern weitergehen, dass sie in ein weiteres Jahr des Krieges gehen. Und ich glaube, fast jeder Ukrainer, wenn nicht sogar jeder, hat Opfer gebracht, kennt Menschen, die gestorben sind, hat Familie verloren und ist von diesem Drama betroffen. Und dass das jetzt weitergehen soll, ohne dass eine Perspektive erkennbar ist, ist natürlich eine sehr, sehr bittere Erkenntnis.
Ja, es geht nicht richtig voran. Das sagen mittlerweile auch viele Militärexperten, die durchaus für Waffenlieferung und dergleichen waren, die auch sich sehr gegen diese Idee von Verhandlungen ausgesprochen haben. Wir hören mal weiter.
Auf der anderen Seite, was man positiv sagen kann, sehen die Ukrainer natürlich nach einem Jahr Krieg, wie sehr der Westen nach wie vor an ihrer Seite steht. Also der Besuch von US-Präsident Biden in Kiew, ich war selber auch da, das ist von den Ukrainern schon wirklich gefeiert worden als etwas, was ihnen Rückhalt vermittelt hat. Ich meine, das sind natürlich die großen Bilder und es ist ja, die Ukrainer verstehen das natürlich auch entsprechend zu vermarkten. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, das war so ein positives Zeichen. Und auch das, was wir jetzt erlebt haben, dass ja nun endlich mal Waffen geliefert werden, über die so lange debattiert wurde. Das sind positive Zeichen. Nichtsdestotrotz, auch militärisch muss man sagen, ist die Ukraine mittlerweile am Tiefpunkt angelangt. Also das müssen wir nicht beschönigen, was wir im Moment im Land erleben, sind an einigen Fronten die bittersten und schlimmsten Kämpfe, die man bisher erlebt hat. Es gibt keine offiziellen Zahlen über Opfer. Aber was man sich als Reporter dort zusammenreiben kann, wenn man einfach mal hinguckt, kann man das nicht hoch genug einschätzen, was da an Tribut gezahlt wird, auch an toten Soldaten.
Das ist auch ein großes Problem, dass wir diese Opferzahlen nicht kennen, dass man immer wieder Gerüchte hört, auch von Leuten, die so in der Medienplace sind, die dann schon mal intern so ein bisschen gesteckt bekommen. Möglicherweise sieht es für die Ukraine, was die Opferzahlen anbelangt, mindestens genauso schlimm aus wie für die Russen, wenn nicht sogar schlimmer. Solche Sachen hört man dann mal. International kann man noch mal mehr dann vielleicht erfahren. Aber es ist sehr, sehr düster, was sie jetzt hier beschreibt.
Also ich habe es gerade rausgesucht, auch Paul Ronzheimer vor zwei Tagen. Meine Gedanken zum Kriegsverlauf. Die Ukraine wird Bachmut verlieren, was kleingeredet werden wird und so weiter und so fort. Mehrere Tweets hin und hin weg. Als ich sie gerade suchte, habe ich gesehen, hat sie auch noch mal genauso auf Englisch geschrieben. Also es scheint ihm auch eine sehr wichtige Botschaft jetzt zu sein, dass es hier ganz anders aussieht, als immer erzählt wurde.
Ja, wir hören weiter.
Also ich gebe mal ein Beispiel. Ich war in Kharkiv. In Kharkiv gibt es einen Riesenfriedhof. Da werden jeden Tag mehrere Soldaten, die einfach aus dem Osten kommen, begraben. Das sind Bilder, die jetzt nicht immer jedem präsent sind, aber die zeigen natürlich, das sind die Toten. Und von den Verletzten reden wir noch gar nicht. Was ich selber bei den Paarbesuchen, die ich gemacht habe an der Front, erlebt habe, ist ein Krieg, also den kann man sich nicht bitter genug vorstellen. Dort sind teilweise Soldaten, die haben den russischen Angreifern nichts entgegenzusetzen, außer ihre Kalaschnikow und werden da manchmal auch einfach überrannt.
Das kennen wir auch. Von anderer Seite wird uns das sehr häufig beschrieben. Ja, Putin schickt die im Prinzip beim Klapspaten los und dann müssen die sehen. Und das stimmt.
Dieser Klapspaten von 1860 oder so.
Dass das wirklich so ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite sieht es auch sehr schlimm aus, wie Eigendorf hier sagt. Und ich sage dann auch, das ist jetzt hier bei MDR in so einer Runde, die ich auch nur mitbekommen habe, weil Matthias mir das geschickt hat. Aber das müsste eigentlich viel, viel präsenter sein, was wir hier zu hören bekommen. Deswegen hören wir noch mal weiter. Das ist eine lange Antwort von ihr, aber ich finde eine sehr aufrichtige.
Und diese Realität, vor der steht die Ukraine jetzt. Und es ist die Frage, ja, wie lange wird das noch dauern?
Ist es denkbar, dass, sagte neulich mal jemand auch, eine Dame, die wissen muss, dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg verliert?
Ja, ich glaube, wir müssen definieren, was heißt gewinnen und verlieren.
Aha, plötzlich ein ganz anderer Ton.
Jetzt müssen wir das definieren.
Das war ja immer die Sache, dass von denjenigen, die nicht einfach diesen Satz sagen wollten, die Ukraine muss den Krieg gewinnen, gefragt wurde, was ist das Ziel? Und das können mir die Leute auch dann nicht so richtig sagen. Manche sagen, der Status von vor dem Kriegsbeginn muss hergestellt werden. Andere sagen nein, eigentlich der Status von vor 2014. Manche knüpfen daran noch ein Regime-Change in Russland und die Verurteilung von Putin in Den Haag oder einem ähnlich konstituierten Gericht. Nun, das ist ja etwas völlig anderes. Also da reden wir über ganz verschiedene Dinge. Und damit können wir auch nicht sagen, ja, das ist der Gewinn und das wäre der Verlust.
Genau, also wir werden es ja gleich im Detail bei Kluge und Habermas lesen. Ich war ja sehr überrascht. Ich habe beide Sachen erst gestern gelesen. Also ich kannte bisher nur die Diskussion über den Habermas-Text und war dann doch jetzt überrascht, dass er ja ein paar Facetten drin hat, wie zum Beispiel diese Frage, wenn man die Kriegsziele nicht definiert, was soll dann eigentlich der Kriegsgegner davon halten, dass er auf Widerstand stößt, wenn mit ihm alles geschehen kann, wenn er nichts ausschließen kann. So und wir haben niemals über die Kriegsziele gesprochen. Es war richtig verpönt, bei Anne Willen plötzlich nachzufragen. Die einzige Frage, die wir uns jetzt stellen, ist, wann sagt Scholz nicht nur, die Ukraine darf nicht verlieren, sondern muss auch gewinnen?
Katrin Göring-Eckardt hat es jetzt nochmal getwittert zum Jahrestag.
Aber jetzt, wo der Sieg, von dem wir immer noch nicht wissen, was es sein sollte, nicht mehr in Aussicht steht, kommt man plötzlich, ja, wir sollten jetzt mal verständigen, was Sieg oder Niederlage bedeutet. Und jetzt stehen wir vor dem Dilemma, wir haben den Sieg nie definiert, was heißt denn jetzt eigentlich Niederlage? Wenn wir den Krieg dadurch, dass wir niemals ein Kriegsziel formuliert haben und damit die Botschaft gegeben haben, wir generalisieren den Konflikt in alle Richtungen, wo es nur geht, wie weit muss man sich da eine Niederlage eigentlich vorstellen? Und wer hat es in der Hand zu definieren? Also wenn jetzt Kathrin Eigentorff einen Vorschlag macht, was für eine Niederlage ist, ist dann Putin damit einverstanden zu sagen, okay, wenn der Zustand erreicht ist, ist das als Niederlage akzeptiert von mir oder wie weit treibt er es dann eigentlich? Also da haben wir doch bei Habermas so ein paar nicht nur kluge, sondern auch so vorausschauende Sachen, die mir erstaunlicherweise von niemandem schon mal dargelegt wurden, der den Text auch gelesen hat. Ich dachte, die haben den alle gelesen, wenn sie darüber sprechen, aber anscheinend nicht. Und das ist mal wieder sehr aufmerksam gewesen.
Ja, ich habe den Text ja auch jetzt erst gelesen zum Salon und war auch sehr erstaunt, wie doof einen eigentlich Twitter machen kann. Das habe ich gesehen und das war die Lesefähigkeit nicht allzu hoch.
Es ist ja nicht nur Twitter. Ich habe auch Leute im Podcast gesehen, die eine Stunde darüber reden, was Habermas angeblich meinte und überhaupt und so.
Wir hören noch mal ein letztes Mal Eigendorf. Und jetzt habe ich, das wäre jetzt meine Unterstellung, so ein bisschen Eindruck, okay, jetzt hat sie das selbst so gesagt. Und jetzt versucht sie aber nochmal, die heroischen Ukrainer zu beschwören. Wir hören uns das aber trotzdem an, weil ich finde, dass uns nochmal das Dilemma sehr gut vor Augen führt.
So wie ich die Ukrainer, und das ist natürlich immer nur eine Momentaufnahme, erlebe, werden sie nicht zurückweichen. Also die Entschlossenheit der breiten Masse, der Bevölkerung, diesen Krieg weiterzuführen, auch mit allen Opfern, ist sehr groß. Und jetzt ist Präsident Zelensky, jemand, der das natürlich auch sehr schön zu verkaufen weiß. Er hat ja gesagt, an die Russen gerichtet, wir sterben lieber, als dass wir unter eurer Besatzung leben, mit Vergewaltigung und Mord, Entführung von Kindern. Aber das stimmt. Das ist das Gefühl, glaube ich, was viele oder die große Masse der Ukrainer haben. Sie wollen nicht unter russischer Herrschaft leben, weil sie wissen einfach, was das bedeutet.
Aber das bedeutet ja dann, was sie hier aufmacht, Untergang oder Untergang, Tod oder dann das, was da Zelensky ausführt. Und hier würde ich erst einmal deutlich machen, junge Männer in der Ukraine wollen nicht unbedingt rekrutiert werden für diesen Krieg. Ich bringe da mal einen Text mit hinter der Paywall sehr bewusst, damit das nicht so, weil das ist immer ein heikles Thema, aber die Rekrutierung von jungen Männern in der Ukraine ist ein, und wie sie verläuft, zeigt inzwischen sehr deutlich, dass die nicht alle so heroisch dahinter stehen. Und dass auch das eine sehr eigenartige Alternative ist. Sondern da müsste man ja gerade, wenn das jetzt momentan das Dilemma ist, entweder sterben oder von den Russen geknechtet zu werden, dann müsste man ja gerade jetzt schauen, wo ist denn der, und das sagt dann Alexander Kluge, der Notausgang. Über den müssen wir ja jetzt reden. Weil das kann ja jetzt nicht sein, dass man dann sagt, gut, dann sterben wir eben alle. Das ist für den Zelensky, der nicht sterben muss, leicht gesagt. Und das ist auch für Journalisten leicht gesagt. Aber für die auf dem Felde bedeutet das. Und das kann man jetzt gerade über Bachmuth und andere Ortschaften sehr gut nachlesen bei Twitter, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man stirbt und wie dann dieses Verhältnis sich ändert. Da wäre dann mehr stirbt, mehr Russen oder Ukraine.
Wir haben ja schon mal einen Alexander Kluge Text gelesen zum Thema. Das Interview ist ja jetzt aktuell. Aber er hat noch mal denselben Verweis auf den Krieg als solchen. Wenn wir Friedensdemos haben, ist ja immer die Frage, wir haben es ja bei Neubauer gerade gehört. Redet man über die Ukraine oder über Krieg und Frieden? Wenn man über die Ukraine redet, dann ist man, also sieht man sich als Teil mittendrin. Das haben wir ja mit den afrikanischen Stimmen aus Namibia und so besprochen, was das bedeutet. Und Alexander Kluge legt halt auch immer wieder diesen Fokus drauf, dass der Krieg selber jetzt zum Thema wird. Und man sich da erst mal eine Zuschauerposition bringt, die grob gerechnet, wir haben jetzt im Fernsehpodcast diesen einen Clip mitgehört, wie am 24. Februar Majedas Lomka vor Ort war und dann auf irgendeinem Dach noch mal hell erleuchtet in, ich weiß gar nicht, in welcher Stadt sie war wahrscheinlich, dort in Kiew noch mal jetzt sagen, ja, das sind so zwischen 500 und 1000 Tote. So, es hat Eingeldorf grad gesagt, und von den Verletzten ganz zu schweigen, was ja bedeutet hochgerechnet, vielleicht kann man es noch höher treiben, aber Faktor 10 sollte man ja schon anlegen. Also auf jeden Mord, der da jetzt stattfindet, kommen zehn Mordversuche. Also haben wir es gerade mit einer Weltregion zu tun, in der jeden Tag mindestens 10.000 Mordversuche stattfinden. Und das bedeutet ja irgendwas, unabhängig davon, wer hat vor einem Jahr mal angefangen, wer hat vor 20 Jahren sich schon provozieren lassen oder wie auch immer. Sondern einfach dieser Zustand muss ja mal Thema, also darf ruhig jetzt mal Thema für sich einfach sein, dass man sich jetzt nur in die Zukunft nur nach vorne schaut und fragt, wie kann man die Zahl jetzt mal ein bisschen runter dimmen?
Ganz genau.
So und jetzt haben wir einfach diese Geschichten von der einen Seite mit einem Spaten und auf der anderen Seite ja, die haben gar nichts mehr, um sich zu verteidigen. Also die einen haben Spaten und die anderen haben dann nicht mal mehr einen Spaten.
Kalaschnikow oder nichts. Und wir hören jetzt...
Wenn man so Weltgeschichte schreiben will und glaubt, da gibt es noch Gewinner oder sowas.
Da gibt es noch das Heroische. Ne, das ist nicht. Und wir hören jetzt auch noch mal einen ganz anderen oder einen Ton, der in diese Richtung geht, aber auch genauso überraschend oder für mich eigentlich noch überraschender. Und zwar Marina Weisband war bei Anne Will zugeschaltet und war dann auch nachher noch mal in der Woche bei Ilna und hat in Variation das Gleiche gesagt. Wir hören das jetzt mal, was sie dort bei Anne Will sagt. Und auch das ist ganz erstaunlich, denn das hätte jetzt auch so von anderen formuliert werden können, die sehr hart angegriffen werden dann auf Twitter. Aber wir hören uns mal an, was Marina Weissmann hier sagt.
Und dann können wir diesen Krieg so schnell wie möglich zu beenden. Nämlich, dass Joe Biden noch im November gesagt hat, im Prinzip, wenn du einmarschierst, wird die NATO nichts machen. Hätte er gesagt, wenn du einmarschierst, kannst du überhaupt nicht wissen, was dann passiert. Dann könnte Putin es sich dreimal überlegt haben. Aber viele Ukrainer betrachten genau diesen Satz als eine Einladung. Als, komm her, fallen die Ukraine ein. Und dann geben wir der Ukraine stückchenweise immer genauso viele Waffen, dass sie sich gerade gegen dich verteidigen kann. Er hat wortwörtlich gesagt, ich bin bereit, aus der Ukraine ein zweites Afghanistan zu machen. Kein Konflikt, der für seine Schnelligkeit bekannt ist. Aber ich kann nicht damit leben, dass in Zuge dieser Geopolitik Russland arm zu bluten, ukrainische Leben unter die Räder gelang.
Wir hatten einige Leute, die das so formuliert hatten in den vergangenen Monaten nicht, dass das ein Abnutzungskrieg wird aus geopolitischem Interesse. Nein, es geht hier nur um die Ukraine kämpfen für unsere Freiheit. Und Marina Weißmann bringt es meinen Augen ganz klar auf den Punkt. Sie zeigte auch, wo vielleicht ein Fehler des Westens war, dass Biden tatsächlich rumlavierte und da nicht diese Ansage machte. Und dass die ganzen Sachen, die dann kamen, für Putin natürlich auch eine Überraschung hatten dadurch. Und er dann nicht durchmarschieren könnte. Aber diese Überlegung hätte man mit dem entsprechenden Drohpotenzial vielleicht das generell verhindern können, finde ich erst mal sehr gut. Und ist aber auch eine Sache, die wir nicht mehr beantworten können. Aber das zweite scheint mir noch viel wichtiger, dass hier auch von der Seite, die absolut solidarisch ist mit der Ukraine, das Problem des Absennutzungskrieges und der geopolitischen Interessen mal ganz deutlich benannt wird. Und sie hat das dann die Woche später nochmal bei Ilna wiederholt. Also das ist etwas, was wir sehr zu Kenntnis nehmen müssen. Und da nochmal vielleicht das Einordnen mit dieser unglaublichen Wut, gegenüber denen die Verhandlungen fordern, gegenüber Kluge und Habermas und Co. Dass vielleicht manche diese Wirklichkeit auch immer mehr auf sich zurasen sehen und so aus einer letzten Aktion der Realitätsverweigerung heraus sagen, ne, also jetzt aber nochmal richtig jetzt voller Unfass zu tun, als hätten die, die für Verhandlungen hier in Berlin oder sonst wo demonstrieren, eigentlich den Krieg zu verantworten. Ne, so wird es dann auch nicht mehr schön.
Genau, schließen wir das mal ab mit, und ich will es auch nochmal, du hast es auch schon gesagt, aber Marina Weisband gibt hier Joe Biden eine Mitschuld. So wie auch Heusgen in seinem Buch, wir lesen es gleich, überlegt, ja, wenn Obama damals das mit der roten Linie, der ja angemerkt hat, wenn in Syrien Giftgas eingesetzt wird von Assad, ja, lassen wir uns das nicht gefallen, dann reagieren wir. Und dann hat er doch nicht reagiert. Und das war vielleicht das Signal an Putin, ach so, die reden immer nur, die machen dann nichts. Und dass man, dass er wirklich dachte, okay, ich fahre mit so einem 60 Kilometer langen Konvoi nach Kiew und dann sehen schon alle, es wird sich nicht lohnen, den Krieg einzusteigen, und dann sind sie aber doch eingestiegen. Das vielleicht, und das kann dann wirklich nur die Geschichtsschreibung irgendwie zeigen später, man wirklich eine Situation geschaffen hat, in der Putin festgenagelt ist. Der britische Verteidigungsminister Wallace hat jetzt in der BBC noch mal darauf hingewiesen, wir wissen, 97 Prozent der russischen Armee ist auf ukrainischem Boden. So, alle, es ist komplett gebunden. Alle militärische Handlungsfähigkeit Russlands ist jetzt gerade in der Ukraine gebunden. Es gibt keinen vor, es gibt keinen zurück. Es ist völlig egal, was in Moskau noch entschieden wird. Man hat nur die Möglichkeiten, die jetzt gerade die Generäler alle verwenden. Da steht nicht noch irgendwo ein Bataillon rum oder da kann man nicht noch jemanden schicken. Da kommt auch kein neuer Jahrgang oder sowas, sondern das ist einfach eine festgefahrene Situation. Und in der BBC wurde am 16. Februar die Sendung mit folgendem Gedankengang eröffnet. Also die Newsnight-Sendung, die dortigen, sagen wir mal, das ist heute schon all die Tagesthemen.
Den Eingehen der Munition aus?
Genau. Es ist jetzt die Frage, geht den Ukrainen die Munition aus, bevor den Russen die Buddies ausgehen, die Leichen in dem Sinne? Das ist so makaber, aber das scheint jetzt so Stand der Dinge zu sein. Wir haben es ja auch vom amerikanischen Chair of the Chief Joints of Staff gehört, von Mark Milley. Es hat sich, was die Nature of War angeht, in den 100 Jahren nichts verändert. Man steht auf dem Boden und kämpft halt gegeneinander. Bei der BBC hat man dann auch hier so einen ehemaligen Chairman da zu Gast. Und redet mit dem mal genau diese Fragestellung. Also da kriegt man ein paar andere Infos und eine andere Bandbreite, als jetzt hier von Eigendorf das so nachgeschoben. Das hätte sie ja auch mal im ZDF schon vor ein paar Monaten...
Das hätte der große Bericht werden müssen und sehr viel früher. Wir springen nochmal ganz kurz zur letzten Folge. Und zwar habe ich Nachrichten bekommen über Instagram zu unserer Thematisierung von was ist im Fitnessstudio erlaubt, inwieweit darf geflirtet werden. Instagram, das ist ja meine Datingplattform. Nein. Also mir schrieb der Hörer Max, dass er sehr froh war, dass wir erst sagen, oh, das ist ein vermintes Feld und uns dann aber trotzdem reingewagt haben. Und das sollten wir ruhig häufiger tun. Dann die Hörerin Nika schrieb, sie geht einfach ins Fitnessstudio, um Sport zu machen. Und sie begründete das sehr schön. Sie sagte ja, ich habe ja die Geräte nicht zu Hause. Also das heißt, das, was sie gerne an Übung machen will, kann sie nur da machen. Und da ist aber nicht sonst noch irgendein Gedanke dabei. Und sie möchte einfach da möglichst ungesehen. Also sie hat das eigentlich so ausgedrückt, wenn sie könnte, dann würde sie sich das Fitnessstudio nach Hause holen, dann würde sie gar nicht dahingehen. Das finde ich ist ein gutes Argument nochmal dafür, also nicht alle gehen dahin, weil es eine Single Party ist. Und es ist ja auch nicht eine Single Party, sondern es sind ja auch viele da, die verpartnet sind. Aber dennoch würde ich auch sagen, ja, das mag so sein. Aber ich glaube, dass man auch eine, also es gibt ja solche und solche Flirts und solche Atmosphären. Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage, wie es ausgestaltet ist. Und das sind ja gerade das Interessante, was auch verlernt wird natürlich durch dann sowas wie eine Pandemie, wie man eigentlich Menschen begegnet, welche Nähe man herstellt, welche nicht oder wem man eher verbindlich ansprechen kann und wer nicht, das sagt man da. Mary Jane, die du ja kennst, unsere liebe Freundin vom Corporate Therapy Podcast, hat auf was Interessantes hingewiesen und gesagt, ja, ja, das ist so leicht gesagt. Die Frauen wollen ja nicht von den Männern angeguckt werden. Aber, sagt sie, ja, aber die Männer wollen auch nicht von den Männern angeguckt werden. Das heißt, sie hat nochmal da deutlich gemacht, naja, es ist immer auch die Frage, von wem wird man angeguckt. Und das wäre dann ja auch immer so etwas, was untersagt ist, dass Männer Männer angucken. Also wo der Fitnessstudioraum zu sehr als homosozialer Raum erkennbar wird, da sagen die anderen auch, nee, nee, klotz mal lieber nicht. Also auch nochmal ein interessanter Aspekt. Und dann hat mir noch ein guter Bekannter geschrieben, ich weiß nicht, ob ich den bei Namen lernse, ich nenne ihn mal A-Punkt. Er geht in Köln in ein Fitnessstudio und sagt, da wird noch geflirtet und er hat eine ehemalige Mitschülerin, die ihn da im Fitnessstudio entdeckt hat. Und die kommt jetzt immer, wenn er trainiert, die Sache ist neu, er trainiert immer ab 23 Uhr. Naja, ich habe ihm geraten, vielleicht dann doch mal langsam ins Gespräch zu kommen, damit die arme junge Frau nicht mehr zu diesen Nachtzeiten im Fitnessstudio rumtornen muss.
Also wir stellen auch interessiert und sehr erleuchtend fest, was eigentlich die kontroversen Themen in einem politischen Podcast sind. Wir sind ja ein sehr politischer Podcast. Aber die Reaktion auf, du besprichst ein Buch, wie Musik komponiert wird und ob es einen Unterschied zwischen Unterhaltung und so weiter.
Da gibt es mehr Kommentare.
Oder Fitnessstudio. Was macht man im Fitnessstudio? Ich will nur mal darauf hinweisen, wir kommen aber auch noch häufiger drauf zurück. Es ist auch ein Thema für die Bühne. Mir ging es gar nicht so sehr um das Fitnessstudio als Fitnessstudio, sondern das Fitnessstudio als Kulisse für Debatten, die bei YouTube geführt werden. Also nicht um alle, die da sind und sehr viele filmen sich nicht, sondern diejenigen, die sich filmen, also deren Artefakte, dann später auf YouTube landen zum Nachschauen für Hunderttausende, die auch selber vielleicht gar keinen Bezug im Fitnessstudio haben oder so. Was wird denen eigentlich gesagt über, wie man sich im Fitnessstudio verhält? Und da gibt es dieses Phänomen, aber da bringe ich nochmal Beispiele mit, dass Frauen, die sich filmen, nochmal extra Videos machen, nur aus den Szenen, in denen im Hintergrund Männer sie anstarren.
Und das sind wie gerade Trems bei TikTok. Und da ist es wohl sehr gut mit Klicks zu generieren und das sorgt dann für Aufmerksamkeit. Und jeder hat natürlich eine Meinung dazu. Guckt der? Guckt der wirklich? Gafft der? Und sofort sind die Kommentarspalten voll und entsprechend der Algorithmus getriggert.
Genau. Und da kriegt man dann auch den Kulturschock mit, dass man denkt, wenn man keinen Bezug zum Fitnessstudio hat, das sei ein Fitnessstudio. Und dann geht man, nachdem man solche Videos geguckt hat, vielleicht wirklich mal ins Fitnessstudio und stellt fest, ach so, ihr findet das, es ist eigentlich total langweilig. Ihr guckt niemanden, niemanden an und ihr spricht auch niemanden, niemanden an. Jeder macht seinen Sport für sich. Und im Grunde wären lieber alle gerne alleine. Aber da gibt es halt die Geräte nicht. Also geht man dann dahin, wo die Geräte sind und findet sich halt damit ab, dass da auch noch andere Leute sind. Was dann nur nochmal sozusagen die Situation, in der eben auch sichtbar jemand sich filmt. Man weiß, okay, eigentlich wollen wir uns ja alle in Ruhe lassen und plötzlich bringt da jemand 100.000 Leute als Publikum mit.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt schon diese Tendenz, aber wir bleiben an dem Thema dran.
Da bleiben wir dran.
Dass man nach bestimmten Zeiten geht, um flirten zu können. Und das ist dann nachmittags um zwei vielleicht nicht so möglich als abends um 19 Uhr. Wir gehen zu unseren Salon-Themen über. Also wir werden sprechen über das Buch von Christoph Heusgen, Führung und Verantwortung. Ein Rückblick auf Merkels Außenpolitik und ein Blick in die Zukunft. Wie könnte die Rolle Deutschlands künftig aussehen? Wir spinsen eigentlich nicht durch Schlüsselloch. Wir müssen da mal ganz anders drüber reden, auch über diese Art des Buches. Was darf eigentlich verraten werden von dem Sicherheitsberater von Angela Merkel und was nicht? Und was können wir doch noch zwischen den Zeilen so lesen? Dann Habermas-Essay aus der Süddeutschen Zeitung über Verhandlungen, warum der Westen da besonders gefordert ist, gerade weil er Waffen liefert. Dann das hochinteressante Interview zum Notausgang aus dem Krieg von Alexander Kluge. Und ich habe dann, wie schon versprochen, dabei die Herrschaft der Inzidenzen und Evidenzen von dem Soziologen Richard Münch, der sich auch auf Luhmann dann bei diesem Buch bezieht und sagt, was passiert eigentlich, wenn wir uns von Inzidenzen leiten lassen? Was ist eigentlich eine ausdifferenzierte Gesellschaft? Und welche Ebenen werden dann plötzlich so zusammengebunden? Und inwieweit wird eigentlich die Regierung immer mehr von dem Zientismus regiert? Ich finde, das ist ein sehr kluger Debattenbeitrag. Und für die, die fanden, man müsste eigentlich da mit der Kritik, die wir da schon geäußert hatten, an Maiti weitergehen. Da wird es also dann diese Richtung was geben. Außerdem ein Text darüber über die Rekrutierung in der Ukraine von Soldaten. Dann ein Text zu den afrikanischen Staaten, die sich nicht einfach so hinter den Westen stellen. Außerdem ein Text über IMDb. Das ist natürlich eine der wichtigsten Datenbanken, auf denen ich mich online herumtreibe. Die Filmdatenbank gehört auch zu Amazon. Wyatt hat einmal die Leute getroffen, die diese Datenbank die ganze Zeit vollschreiben. Das ist wie Wikipedia, ist aber viel älter als Wikipedia. Hochinteressant. Ja, fünf Jahre älter. Ich werde mich richtig aufregen zum Schluss. Ich habe den Text vor zwei Wochen gelesen, aber es ist nicht abgeklungen. Ich habe es gestern kurz überflogen und war schon wieder sauer. Antigone in leichter Sprache an der Münchner Kammer spielen. Ich weiß noch gar nicht, was ich schlimmer finde. Das oder die Kritik dazu?
Ist sie auch in leichter Sprache, oder?
Ich würde sagen, ja.
Ein leichter Gedankengang. Das ist sehr viel. Ich beschränke mich wie immer auf fünf Texte. Drei davon hast du ja schon genannt. Die Ernährungsthemen. Ich will darauf verweisen, dass es Anfang Februar einen sehr guten, wie nennt man das? Bei einem Spiegel Cover Story oder so zum Thema Ernährung gab. Könnte ich auch im Salon vorstellen, aber will ich dann doch lieber knüpfen an eine ausführlichere Departierung des Themas Ernährung. Denn neben Fitnessstudio und Musik kann man ja noch ein kontroverses Thema reinbringen. Ernährung, bald im Podcast. Ich lese gleich noch Marcel Fratschers Text Das Plädoyer gegen den Primat der Wirtschaft. Womit er, ist ganz erstaunlich eigentlich, dass er dann doch immer nochmal im Verruf ist. Vielleicht wird er doch nochmal Bundesbankpräsident oder sowas. Aber gleichzeitig auf, also immer publizistisch solche Granaten wirft. Und wir werden die 80 Seiten von Annalena Baerbock zur feministischen Außenpolitik lesen. Denn ja, es ist wirklich so ein kleines Oje drinnen. Ich werde begrifflich sowohl den Teil feministisch als auch Außenpolitik hinterfragen. Plus, ich glaube, da steckt auch so eine kleine Unbedachtheit drinnen. Die Pointe muss ich mir aber für den Salon als Safe Space aufheben. Denn vielleicht lohnt sich auch die männliche Perspektive nicht komplett zu vergessen bei manchen Angelegenheiten. Und hier scheint es mir so einen blinden Fleck zu geben. Und ich meine das jetzt nicht so gefühlig oder so, sondern es scheint hier ein strukturell für Deutschland sehr bedeutsam, gerade wenn wir mit Heusgen anfangen als Außenberater. Und wie geht Außenpolitik und so weiter? Scheint es mir da einen ganz großen blinden Fleck zu geben in dieser feministischen Außenpolitik, die uns vielleicht noch in die eine oder andere Bredouille bringt? Aber das dann im Salon.
Genau. Der Salon bucht man für diejenigen, die bei Apple sind, direkt über Apple, also die, die es bequem mögen. Außerdem für diejenigen, die bei Patreon schon angemeldet sind und es bequem mögen, ist das da auch möglich. Aber der Salon kann vor allem gebucht werden über Steady. Das ist das, was wir präferieren. Da hat man das All-Inclusive-Paket.
Das ganze Angebot.
Das ganze Angebot mit auch einen Kapitelmarken und dergleichen. Und ich sollte darauf, wie es mich ein Hörer gestern auf Twitter hin, mal darauf hinweisen, dass man den ja dann, wenn man das als Jahresabo abschließt, schon ab 2, 50 Euro im Monat bekommt. Denn ihm war gar nicht klar, dass der so günstig ist, schrieb er, dass man also schon dabei eintreten kann. Und ja, das sei dann hiermit gesagt. Und vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Also wer den Podcast unterstützen will, beziehungsweise den Salon hören will, kann dort gerne uns unterstützen und kann den Salon buchen. Am liebsten über Steady, aber alle anderen Wege sind natürlich auch genehm.
So ist es. Also gehen wir mal in den Salon. Bis gleich.